[Music]
okay hi everyone welcome to today's
class we're going to talk about
um attacking games in the Sicilian so
we're gonna I have five games prepared
we will see how many we can get through
hopefully all of them also included some
of my games I I'm an E4 player and I
like facing the Sicilian so we'll be
looking at things from White's point of
view and some ideas for white of how to
attack in a Sicilian
so
um okay so we have people in class and
people on stream
so I'll try to pay attention to both
so first game we're gonna look at is
between Alexander casting and Irina
crush this is from the 2021 online
Olympiad and
um
I think this was some kind of a playoff
between us and Russia so very important
game
so Alexander costumes
um
she's actually playing really well
lately she has won recently won the
women's Grand Prix so very strong player
in the Irina crashes on eight-time U.S
women's champion
so very high level game
so it starts so casting is playing White
Knight f36 and crushes are very avid
it's an avid Sicilian player she really
sticks to her Sicilians
and Knight C6 so we have the fortnite
Sicilian or the classical Sicilian
so it's also of course possible in this
position black has several moves on
Knight C6 is one
A6 is the night orph
oops
I forgot this is not easy in chess base
E6 with the shaveningen and G6 with the
dragon so a lot of moves here for
uh for black oops didn't mean to do that
so
black chooses to play Knight C6 which is
one of irena's pet lines she does like
to play this classical Sicilian quite a
lot
so there's again for white quite a few
setups here so white can always choose
to play Bishop E2 and just Castle
kingside just like in any kind of
Sicilian
and also there is this line with Bishop
C4
and the downside of this variation for
white like this bishop E3 move which is
a move that I like to play against a lot
of Sicilians this English attack like
Bishop B3 F3 Queen D2 doesn't really
work out really well here because
there's annoying Knight G4 move
and if the bishop moves back unlike in
the night or when the queen goes to B6
this Knight on D4 is under attack
so for the so Bishop G5 is played which
is I think is the most challenging move
here for black
Pang goes to E6 because black doesn't
really want to allow taken the Knight so
Queen D2
Bishop E7 and castle
so in a lot of Sicilians we do see this
um
opposite side castles because black is
taking so long to develop and castle and
do all that
it gives white enough time to Castle on
the queen side and also because in open
Sicilian when we play D4 CD in Knight D4
we open the queen side first I mean we
open the queen side very quickly so it
doesn't take that long to K to Castle
down the queen side because usually
castling on the queen side takes longer
right because you have to develop three
pieces so it's a bit faster in the
Sicilians and of course black is taking
so long to develop so Bishop G5 E6 22
Bishop B7 and castle and in this
position Irina played A6 and I think A6
is um
on some lines can be considered a bit
the bs2 even
the main line here is to play castle
F4 so White's idea is to oops attack on
this side and black is of course going
to be attacking on the queen side
so Knight D4 takes Queen A5 and this is
a huge theory in this lines
with the idea that E5 immediately
doesn't work out because after Knight D5
this doesn't quite work out because this
hangs with a check
but in the game instead
what am I doing
A6 was played and now
takes
and black basically loves this taking on
F6 and so now taking on F6 is not ideal
because after takes takes takes the C6
Pawn also hangs sometimes in this lines
black sacrifices this pawn and allows
this
and just gives up this pawn and then
plays against the structure but usually
in positions where this Pawn is on B7
not when they also ruin the Empire
structure
so for this reason Irena takes she takes
F6 the bishop goes to C4 and now black
castles
which looks like a very scary decision
for black because black has ruined their
Pawn structure and
castled kingside but
if we think about it how to attack in
this position for white it's not very
clear right because
pushing this pawns doesn't
really go that far
because we can eat black will just
simply ignore it so for example if white
goes G4
even if I allow all of this it's
possible for me to even allow this let's
say something like this okay maybe I'm
playing a bit Reckless
but like for example black allows
something like this and all of a sudden
this bishop comes to life right then and
then this Rook is attacking so this
actually might even benefit black this
kind of Pawn pushes
so all of a sudden because this Pawn
structure has changed
uh this pawn attack well is not so clear
anymore
and uh I don't know why this phone keeps
moving and we know whenever we Castle on
opposite sides is um pound attacks are
very common because when our King is on
the other side of the board we don't
have to worry about opening that side of
the board anymore
so instead uh she plays rugachimon and
kasinuk is attacking with the pieces
so after King h8 which makes a lot of
sense because the king's position is
compromised so what I said about the
pawn attacks not being so clear even so
this king's position is not exactly safe
right because in the long term it's
possible that this black king will come
under attack
so it's not like the safest King even
though there is like no direct pawn
attack coming so King h8 is a very
sensible move because in the future she
can bring the Rook into defense and to
rookie 3. so White's idea is to attack
with the pieces because there is an open
G file
on the king it makes a lot of sense to
bring a rook into the attack
and if we look at the position so this
Knight here is a bit useless because
cannot really go to D5 and this bishop
would actually prefer if this E4 Pawn
was in here
because then
the bishop could go to D3 and attack
this Pawn
so it makes more sense for white to
attack with the heavy pieces so Rook G8
and now F4
with the idea of
Shifting the pieces to the king side so
D5 Queen E2
Shifting the queen
to H5 and also because of the pin the
bishop is not hanging
oh my God what is wrong with this
program what's happening
no I mean it's uh whatever it's nothing
wrong with the program it's like I click
on the thing and it moves on a square so
there's nothing actually wrong with the
program
no no no
okay so now the position starts to get
quite crazy also I have to mention this
is a rapid game and of course in Rapid
games especially like rapid online games
we see a lot of um
a lot more excitement a lot more tactics
so Bishop D6 and now F4 is hanging and
also
the C4 Bishop might be hanging right
because we're breaking this pin
so white plays E5
takes takes
so of course something like this we can
take with the Rook we can take with the
pawn this is just horrible this Pawn
structure
so instead flag moves the bishop
attacking The Rook
the row goes to the other side of the
board and now that things really get
Tactical
so black decides to check
and takes the bishop which I understand
is an understandable decision because if
you don't take the bishop in this
position then this bishop will actually
slide back and this change of the pawn
structure is going to be very helpful
for white because the bishop went from
um
like this position right where the
bishop is locked in all of a sudden the
bishop went to this Pawn structure where
this diagonal is now open so the bishop
will go to D3 and just attacking this H7
Square
and if we think about it and think about
Black's King this King doesn't have that
many Defenders because if we just look
at the position
again
so the C5 Bishop so if you think about
what's a Target is this H7 Pawn right
that's what white is going for so this
C5 Bishop cannot be of use this bishop
is way too far away like it's really
hard to imagine
any kind of a route for this bishop to
get to the king side quickly like if the
bishop was on G6 or F5 would be very
helpful for black and so these are the
main Defenders and it's also possible
that
maybe like Rook A7 F6 somehow bring this
rook in something
um something to do in the future
um
this chat is so chaotic like I don't
even understand what it's about
yeah
okay so in this position black decides
to take on C4 which actually is not
accurate so the correct way of playing
was to play
to take on G2
Queen H5
I was analyzing this with an engine it's
kind of hard to analyze without
and there's this move of Rook G3 which
is removing the defender even though
it's giving up a pawn and Rook D3 is a
really nice move because without this
rule because this king is super lonely
right and something like Bishop D3 would
be game over so taking this is of course
very bad because you just get mated here
so this is impossible
so Rook G3 is a strong move so
black has to take
but now after something like Queen F7
again this king is in a vulnerable
situation taking is impossible because
of mate and uh and black
um
like the position is very dangerous for
black here
um okay but instead she decides to take
on C4
and now white plays Knight E4
and the difference is
now Queen G2 loses tactically because
the Knight is part of the game and then
earlier at some point I mentioned like
this Knight is so useless right because
it was on C3 couldn't go to E4 there's a
pawn there's a white Pawn here and it
couldn't go to D5 because it would just
be captured but not Knight joins the
attack
so even though black is up a piece more
attackers are joining the game so this
is actually becoming very problematic
for black and here there is a tactical
solution here already taking advantage
of this Knight being in the game
so white can already take and the
problem is after take Knight F6 the king
cannot run on the G file
because we take the queen
and if the King goes to
86 or h8 then
we're just going to Simply win a queen
so Queen H6
and if Rook G7 this leads to that
Arabian like a version of Arabian meat
with the Knight and a rook
and if
King is seven
then we take on G8 and again taking back
is impossible because
mate is coming
so this is this game over
so the only way I think was
um
that Queen G7 and giving up the queen
and again it's taking the coin is not
possible because of meat
which is actually really nice because
black has white has given up all the
pieces just attacking with the Knight
and a rook
so but in this position after taking
this piece basically
um
black is kind of committed to hanging on
to this piece almost because otherwise
the position will be too bad for example
even if the screen moves so Knight F6
will be very strong with the same ideas
it's impossible to defend because of
mate but even if we take on C5 like this
Knight
nope this Knight versus this bishop like
this Knight just completely
dominates this bishop and this Pawn
structure is just really hideous for
black because
I did not mean to do that because if we
look at this pawns they're all on light
squares like every single pan is on the
light square and black has a light
Square Bishop so again it's very hard to
imagine how this bishop is ever going to
join the game so a black just long term
is always going to suffer and almost
like playing down a piece and after
winning this piece back
oh my God stop making this move
uh after winning this piece this Knight
can once again join the attack and black
will face the same kind of problems
so 94 Queen E5 so she took this
and now Rook H5 was played
so again not clear where the screen can
go if the queen goes to this side so we
can so here I don't want to take on C5
as much because
um now this Pawn can move the bishop can
come to life but something like Knight
G5
looks very bad
because H7 is just hanging
um so instead black played F5
and now in this position white found a
tactical way of just already ending the
game
actually after Queen G7 the land that I
had analyzed was takes takes on here
again like this we see this is the
second time we see trading pieces and
which is very interesting because when
we talk about attacking we know like
when you're attacking you're not
supposed to trade pieces
but here we're trading our opponents
basically only defending defensive piece
and once you get rid of this piece then
plug just has no more Defenders left so
it's just the king and the queen alone
and white has a queen Knight and a
Rooker title to attack with and black
only has one Defender so that's not um
that's not a formula
for success to have one Defender against
three attackers
so instead F5 was played and now there
is a really
beautiful move here by white
so now because of the king's position
like if white could take on H7 it'll be
Checkmate and now we see how the screens
are facing off
so now tactically white is just
completely winning with this beautiful
move of Knight G5
so threatening made and threatening the
queen so taking is impossible because
mate
and it's impossible to defend both at
the same time so in the game
block went Queen C7
and again it's possible to take on H7
but here white has a really brilliant
move
because the queen
cannot really move away from attacking
H7 so
I might find a way to deflect the queen
like this is possible but
and now this attack is really slowing
down because white has run out of pieces
even though white won the queen
now they don't really have any more
pieces left to attack with
so instead in the after Queen C7 white
plays oops Queen E5 really beautiful
move attacking this queen on C7 and
checking the king so taking is
impossible because of the checkmated we
saw
so it's just a really beautiful
checkmate and there's really no other
move Queen G7 again checkmate
so inside Rook G7 was played
and after Rook G7
she continues with the same idea
that the pieces are are overworked it's
actually in this position taking only
five it would still be impossible
because of Rook d8 so for example if I
pass the move this is still a mistake
funny enough
but in this position taking advantage of
this overworked Queen White plays
another beautiful move Rook d8
and after taking
it's just checkmate
so really powerful game by customer
great attacking game
yeah a lot of like tactical teams
involving in one game
going after this King and
um I I thought this was a really well
game played by casting the Rooks in and
then sacrificing that night
um that Bishop just to bring the knight
in and this really nice tactic with
um Queen A5 followed by where are we
like this queen E5 following the same
team with Rook to d8
okay so this was our first example
um
let's move on to the next one
okay so I'm seeing both YouTube and
twitch chat so it's a bit chaotic but
okay
so let's move on
so the second one is actually one of my
games so this was from the Olympiad and
this was actually in person Olympiad so
the one that we saw was online Olympiad
and the Olympiad is uh it's one of my
favorite tournaments it's a team
tournament you know you represent your
country you have teammates very unusual
for chess to have teammates usually you
just play on your own so this was from
2018 Olympiad I was playing on third
board for the US team
and we're doing quite well the whole
Olympiad were fighting for medals we
ended up losing to Ukraine in the final
match and within medal otherwise we're
having a really great event so this one
uh this one we are playing against Italy
and I think this was in the middle of
the tournament I think this was like
around seven or eight it wasn't towards
the end but at this point it was like
important to keep winning matches so we
could be on the top words
so I'm playing with the white pieces so
what I mean by chaotic because I see
twitch and YouTube chat together so like
they're not like continuous because
there's like two different chats
okay so I'm playing with the white
pieces so I started with the form
and my opponent plays the taimanov
so this is a very different setup from
with just some so in the other position
the pawn was on D6 and here the pawn
stays on D7 which gives black a lot more
flexibility in some regard because now
the bishop in some lines can get out
in many lines actually and sometimes the
pond just stays on D7
and sometimes plug just never plays Pawn
to D6 and if black does manage to play
Pawn to D5 then they get to do it in one
move and in general in all of Sicilians
Black's main idea is to play in Pawn to
D5 and if black manages to trade this
Pawn for this Pawn without like ruining
their Pawn structure without any cup
with the isolated Pond and black is
doing really well
so I played Knight C3 Queen C7
and F4
again one of the lines to play here
another line that I used to play was
this one
and Bishop B4 F3 but I didn't really
like these positions actually I
I think I do better well okay not lately
because lately I've just been struggling
all over the place but like in this Pawn
structures where the pawn structure is
not fixed when the pawn is still on E6 I
kind of had trouble with this position
because this D5 movies coming this E5
movie is coming so I kind of prefer this
more fixed Pawn structures
uh and yeah so there is also oops
Bishop E3 yeah so there's also some
Queenie to remove
uh so instead but I like this F4 line
and I've played uh just several times I
also played this in the world cup so I
have quite a bit of experience here
so she went A6 and
now of course developing with Bishop D3
is not possible the Knight is hanging
and Bishop E3 now that the pawns are on
F4 and E4 can run into Bishop B4
and now Knight so I you take on C6 and
in this position black has three options
all of them are playable taking with
either Pawn or with the queen and they
just lead to very different Pond
structures and it's just a matter of
uh what kind of Pawn structure black
wants to play with so she took with the
b-pawn which I think objectively is
supposed to be the best way for black to
play
Bishop D3 D5
so now in this position it doesn't make
make as much sense for me
to council queenside anymore because
this p-file is open it's going to take
me too many moves and so I'm ready to
Castle on the king side
so I play Queen E2
and Castle here
so the idea for me here is to because
again black is taking a bit of time to
Castle and I'm already developed and
Castle to try to get some kind of an
attack in
and so there's a lot of
um
like I guess um
tension with the pun structures because
black doesn't really want to take only
four even though she did in the game but
then she had a specific idea but
generally like taking on e4 so black
black does have this kind of a pawn
structure right so the spawns are
together it's a pond Island so it makes
sense but once they take only four for
example now we see that the spawns all
of a sudden just become very weak
but at the same time in this kind of
position when once this happens I really
wish my Pawn wasn't an F4 because the
pawn is kind of misplaced misplaced here
so there's this interesting tension and
sometimes black just leaves this Pawn
structure as it is and just doesn't move
it at all sometimes they pla try to play
with C5 and just kind of wait to see
what white does
and sometimes black also just doesn't
Castle because they just try not to get
attacked but here my opponent was
prepared for me and she had a specific
idea in mind so she played Bishop E7
I developed my Bishop castles and I
bring my Rook to the center so now I'm
getting ready to play like E5 and F5 so
not tactically for hers if I playing C5
is not possible because I simply take
and now the bishop is hanging
so this is not a possibility for her
and I can start thinking about pushing
E5 and F5 and so she has to find a move
in this position
so she plays
G6
and so G6
is a very interesting possibility for
her and the point is whenever we have
this moves E6 and G6 the way for me to
react is to play F5 but playing F5 for
me is impossible because after taking
this F5 Pawn is going to hang and if I
play E5 myself
then playing F5 in the future is going
to be almost impossible right unless I
play G4 but because my king is on this
side playing G4 is
um quite dangerous for me because my
king is here so it's quite risky and
like another position if I'm Castle
Queen side like if my king was on C1
here like easily I would just play H4 G4
I just push all these pawns and just
attack but because my king is here it
carries some risks to also open up my
king and now her ideas are simpler
something like C5 Bishop B7
so instead I just um
I think G6 was already a move I wasn't
familiar with so I kind of play like a
almost nothing move just move my king
out of the way because in this position
there are some lines where she can
actually check and take my pawn and then
ask me like where is my compensation so
I was like okay just put your King on H1
so they take only four I take
so she takes
and A5
so I found remembering
um very crazy like well even though this
was like all over four years ago like
she was still playing here very fast
so her idea is to develop her Bishop on
this side and again she has some fun
weaknesses
but if we exchange a lot of pieces if we
exchange going to some kind of an end
game without the heaviest and it might
be very difficult for me to prove any
kind of advantage
so on this in this position
I don't oh my God it's with this arrows
okay
so in this position if we think about
um
if you think about this Pawn structure
so I have a pond majority on the queen
side which means I have more pawns than
my opponent so it's three versus two and
my opponent has upon majority on this
side right they have she has four Pawns
and I have three puns so in the end
games it'd be very
interesting dynamic
so I didn't want a lot of special Basics
because if she plays Bishop H6 it's a
skewer so it will force me to go back
and exchange Bishops and I didn't want
to exchange
so I decided to play Rook F3
so Bishop A6 I move my queen away so she
brings a rook to the center
radiological so in this position I was
thinking maybe Rook C3 can be a threat
and another reason why I wanted my
Bishop to stay on D4
um so the reason I didn't want to play
Pawn to C4 is someone mentioned
in this position it's because I wanted
to keep the option of playing Rook C3
and attacking the spawn because if I
play C4 then attacking this punish will
just be impossible so weaknesses are
really weak if you can attack them if
your opponent has a weakness but you can
never ever reach that weakness then
maybe it's not such a huge problem so I
didn't want to put my Pawn on C4 I
wanted to keep this Roxy 3 mobile live
and
something to keep in mind in the future
because you know when I look at this
position
the C6 Pawn really stands out to me like
I don't have much of an attack even on
this game did end in attack in win I
like I don't really have an attack here
because of this Pawn structure like I'm
not gonna play G4 anymore with the
center open like this because it's just
too risky
um
I'm not cannot go at five she will just
take so
don't have much of an attack so my main
target is now her Queen side pawns the
C6 pawn and this A5 Pawn so so that's
why I wanted to keep this option open
so here she plays Rook d8 very logical
move getting out of the pin and bringing
the Rook into the game
and
I think if I go here I think she can
take Uncle Bishop before
I thought this was a possibility or even
Bishop before immediately
so instead I decided to put my Bishop on
C3 and I was I was expecting her to play
Bishop B4 in exchange this Bishops even
though
this might feel counter-intuitive
um
because you know she has this weak King
so you would think she wants to keep her
Bishop but because my king is on this
open diagonal
that's not the diagonal we're trying to
make that's the diagonal because my
Bishop is on this open diagonal it's
actually quite scary for her so The Rook
is on d8
I cannot go Queen to D4 but if my Queen
ever goes to D4 it's going to be
devastating for her but it's such a
played Rook 2 fe8 and
uh I was like okay so at least now I get
to keep my Bishop it's not much but if I
go A3 at least now she cannot force an
exchange and again like now this A5 Pawn
is a weakness so if in some position
somehow I managed to play Queen E1 this
Pawn on A5 will become a Target
such as to think about how to defend it
and which again it's not so easy for me
to play Queen E1 because there is no
good Square for a rook but you know in a
long term I was like okay maybe she can
face some problems
instead she played Bishop to D6 so I
think she also wasn't super familiar
with this opening I think she had
something prepared she was playing very
fast it's always an unpleasant when your
opponent is playing very fast especially
in this you know really high stakes
tournament like the Olympiad where
you're playing for a team you're playing
for your country
but I think she also wasn't very
familiar so she played this opening and
then she kind of got lost which is
something happens when
we just memorized some Theory we don't
know structures really well this happens
to players of all levels so she played
Bishop D6
and this is actually a huge blunder
because
all of a sudden her King
is becoming super weak and I think her
idea was to counter Queen
the queen D4 with a move like E5 and
like if the Center opens up this can
actually become a huge problem for me
because I have some background
weaknesses right because I have one Rook
on the back Rank and this Rook cannot go
to the back rank because of the bishop
and also then maybe I can run into some
issues here and like she's really well
equipped for the center to open because
all her pieces are in the center and my
Rook is just sitting on F3 for no reason
um so instead
sorry
so Bishop D6 but instead here I have a
very strong move which is Queen H4 and
queen H4 immediately
runs into like she runs into a big
problems because of this move because I
have a very strong thread in this
position so maybe someone can figure out
what a threat is so if it's right to
move
what so white has actually several
threads in the position so okay so very
obvious one is
Queen F6 right because if I put the
queen on the diagonal the bishop that
looks like mate
yeah so if she plays Bishop B7 then
immediately Queen H7 so actually my
biggest threat is Queen H7 because it's
just made
and this is just force mate
so after Queen H1 I think her position
is objectively already
um
I don't know if it's lost but it's very
close to being lost
because if she goes F5 I can still play
here
so now I'm threatening mate so if she
takes
I have made
and if she plays E5
oh I have all kinds of moves here I can
take on F5 take on assistive I can take
on E5 maybe even
I think taking on F5 should be good
so you cannot take back that's mate
and you cannot really take here that's
going to be made I guess Queen F7 will
be moved
but what's wrong with taking on E5
oh
this is such a strange move Bishop to C6
taking on F5 looks good oh I guess
there's Queen E7 Maybe
actually here maybe I even have Rook G3
threatening G6 I mean I have a lot of
threads in this position and okay F5 I
think even if I play something like
Bishop D3 it's not really emotionally
wants to play
and Sasha played E5
and now I go over gauge 3 with the same
threads
so something like this so instead of
check checking I just go Bishop F6
Unstoppable me to next move
so she went F5
out of desperation so after Queen H4 her
position just immediately like one
careless move and
uh her position just falls apart
so now Rook H3 so F5 and now I take
and now
um
now her position is really falling apart
so she took on a five taking here let me
remember what's the way I think Bishop
is six was good
um let's see what's the easiest way of
oh you want is hanging
what's the easiest way of winning here
I think this should be
I mean Bishop A6 looks good to me
and this looks like it's going to be
made because
Rook G6 is still a threat I'm up
material this looks very strong for me
um
um I can't remember what I was thinking
during the game at this point
but I think Bishop E6 is very strong
but in the game she took here
but now she um
she gets mated on this side
so King to F7 and now it takes so now
I'm threatening made in one on
um on F6
so she takes
and now Queen H7 and I'm winning a queen
at the very least because okay so she
cannot go back it's mate
and if she goes
like F6
okay F6 Rook G6 is made and if she goes
here Queen C7
you're not the only one who doesn't
remember always remember what we were
thinking during the game okay this game
is like four years old so
I remember some things this was a
memorable game because this was an
important victory for us that um
because after this I think maybe we
played maybe this was actually around
nine and then we played China the next
round or something
actually let me see I'm gonna maximize
it for a second and see okay now this
was I messed up I'll fix it no this was
round eight so I think in round 10 we
played China with Jerusalem round nine
we played uh what did we play after
Italy
I think we've built another team and
then we drew China and then we lost in
the final round
um oh I think maybe we played Hungary
and then we played Hungary too
and so this was like very important for
us I think we want this match three to
one
so we had one win and two more draws
I think
it was our team was Irina Anna no it was
Anna Irena me and Jennifer you that's
been a voice for Jenna for you but this
particular lineup was Anna Irina me and
Jennifer
I want to say Jennifer Drew she had some
kind of opposite color Bishop end game
and
who else won
maybe everyone Drew maybe no I wasn't
the only one someone else won on the
team okay
this was a long time ago the Glory Days
of our team
okay and we probably don't have time for
every game so let's see which one
um
which one I can show
so there is a Magnus game and there is
okay maybe we can get through two games
actually
do I have an Olympian medal I have a
metal I have a team metal I don't have
an individual one I have one from 2008
which is the last time our team medaled
we were very close
in 2018 I think a draw would have been
enough and last Olympiad also last
Olympia we tied for third in India with
the Indian team
we beat them and then we tied with them
but we lost on tie breaks like very very
close few match points
so that was actually quite
painful
okay
so let's move on to this game so this is
from the European Club Cup in Europe
they have a lot more team tournaments
they have the Bundesliga they have
European Team Championship they have all
kinds of tournaments Club cop is some
kind of a club tournament so it's um not
based on countries or anything it's
whoever the club invites to play
so against two very strong GMS well
actually not white Flair is a strong gym
you recovery from Ukraine almost 2700
um actually not sure who the block
player is
but let's take a look
so Knight F3 D6
so in this position the first game was
size with Knight C6 and then we'll say
day six is a movie six is a move G6 is a
move and here black plays
um some kind of a sideline probably
trying to avoid any kind of theory and
place Bishop to D7
which is
um kind of a non-committal move
trying to avoid any kind of like div
Theory but actually ends up in a bit of
a bad position so F3
Bishop C6 and Bishop B3 so black wastes
a lot of time putting the bishop on C6
usually we get this kind of um
we can't get this kind of a position
from neither
like something like this
and the bishop goes to E6 which is only
one move and the bishop actually does
really well on E6 so we get like this
kind of a structure in the English
attack
but instead black decides to play Bishop
D7 and Bishop to C6
and um
I think there are some downsides to the
bishop being to C6 because the bishop
actually own
on E6 is more annoying for white because
this Knight
goes to C4 the bishop in some point goes
to C4 is just Bishop is a more of a
supportive piece there
so white continues with their same
excuse me with the same plan of Castle
and queen side
and
and this setup that white does white can
do this setup against different kind of
Sicilians for example against the dragon
white does this bishop E3 F3 Queen D2
this English attack against the Knight
Earth against the Chevron Indian against
the classical Sicilian that first game
with side wasn't possible with the same
move order but this is a really nice
setup I've played this for years I
really like it because the attackers is
just kind of flows naturally because
um
she just um this Pawn just um
support this FC plan supports this G4 G5
Port so our idea is to just push this
pawns all the way to G6
um
okay so Pawn to A6
so G4 and now we see kind of a typical
attacking with puns on both on different
parts of the board so
avoid is attacking with this G4 G5 moves
and black is going to be pushing their
Pawns
okay I need some water
another huge downside well this water
did not help
so another big downside for black in
this kind of positions is this Pawn on
D6 so the pawn on D6 is a backward spawn
and the problem is white is completely
controlling this is the five square
so whenever you have a weakness of an
isolated Pawn backwards Pawn you want to
get rid of that pawn because just a
long-term weakness so black would really
love to be able to play D5
but it's not really possible
because D5 is just under control
so like strategically this is a huge
problem for black in these types of
positions
so B5 G5 and the Knight one to E8 and
in this position black really has to
think about what to do with this Knight
because maybe the Knight should go to H5
and the whole point of putting a knight
to H5 is to stop this push of the pawns
because just physically
stopping the pawn from going to H4 and
H5
but this kind of a move oops
can also potentially run into something
like 92 Knight G3
for example if Knight D7 Knight G3
like this kind of a trade is we can see
it's already very problematic for black
because
after a move like Queen H2 this H7 Pawn
this is an open H file right so it
becomes impossible to defend so opening
this H file for free it's not really
something black wants to do
so in this position block went to Knight
to E8 but now
so white plays King B1 which is just a
nice move to play in this positions
where you Castle queenside put the king
away so like this Pawn never ever hangs
with a check or an attack and the king
is just safer there
so sometimes you know they say that
castle and queen side takes two moves
because we Castle Queen side and then
you have to play King B1
the Knight goes to this summer now H4 so
White's idea is very simple to just push
push
so if I like pass the move just to show
what the idea is so like when we go here
the normal reaction is to like take
and then go eight six but here because
we have this sacrifice
and because the K if the King was still
on C1 there would be a bishop G5 check
uh doing this
but because the King has been
uh the King has been moved away then
this is just meat
there's a very loud kid
I mean yes
yeah so and another problem is in this
kind of positions like there's this
bishop that comes from this side
so this is why it's general idea
so black plays before chasing this
Knight away
and A5
so the idea is to start some kind of a
counter play here but again because
black has wasted so much time with
Bishop design Bishop C6 black is just
behind in this position and when we're
playing a sicilian when we're castling
on the other side of the boards and
attacking it really becomes a matter of
tempo and whose attack is going to be
faster so wasting time with Bishop D7
Bishop C6 is uh it's just too much
so Knight goes to G3
so
F5 is a really nice Square for the night
because the Knight cannot be kicked away
and like the long-term problems for
black in this position are still there
for example this this exponent so if my
knight goes to F5 this is going to
really paralyze black because the Knight
cannot move away the pawn will hang so
white doesn't just have to try to
Checkmate their opponent cannot they can
also
try to just go after this this expand
and like try to
um like strategically get a better
position
so Knight goes to C7 trying to go D5
someone mentioned this in the chat
and now Bishop C4 so stopping D5 because
if black gets in D5 then this will solve
a lot of Black's problems because no
more backwards pawn and black spaces
start to get in
so Bishop B5 trying to trade these
pieces
white plays Queenie tomb
so trait and
um
I think this move shows like nerves or
like bug just couldn't play this bad
position anymore back plays G6 which I
can understand because allowing this
Knight on F5 just feels really bad and
when we think about this position and
again thinking about strategically and
not from like a tagging point of view
whenever you have an isolated Pawn or a
backwards Pawn the bishop that is of the
opposite color is the bishop you want to
keep so if you're isolated Pawn like
this D6 Pawn is on a dark Square so
white so black really needs to keep
their light Square Bishop because if we
look at this position this E7 Bishop is
just horrible and the problem with the
A7 Bishop is just always going to be a
bad piece because of the pawn structure
because
all these pawns are here
but because of this all these puns are
in the dark squares it makes the light
Square Bishop very strong
so exchanging
um
there's light Square Bishops like again
strategically is a tough decision for
a black to make but I think black just
didn't wanna
again this mysterious move that I'm
making black just didn't want to allow
this pin and somehow like H5 G6 and just
you know white just rolling
just punched on the board and just
mating this King so
I think black just had to make some kind
of a strategic concession
but after this Exchange
so now the night we'll go to F5 and it
will be impossible to kick this Knight
away from F5 there is no Bishop to do
anything with it and with the Knight on
F5 then this pieces start to hang right
because not this expand just comes under
attack
and um
a lot of problems in Black's positions a
black hat took place I think something
like this and then go D5 and give up
this Pawn but still the position is just
subjectively very bad
instead they play G6
which of course cannot feel good to play
this kind of a move but
um I think they just kind of did it out
of desperation
and immediately H5 of course against G6
H5 is such a natural reaction opening
this file
so taking this
um
doesn't work out because
both of this night hang
so plug is losing
black is losing two pieces
so instead they play tonight to E6
so white takes so in this kind of
position black would love to be able to
take with this Pawn
and put a rook on F7 so they can cover
this H7 square but of course the Knight
is hanging so this is not possible
instead they have to take with the H
Pawn
but now there is nothing to stop this
Rook so this H file is just wide open
so so if this queen somehow lands on H6
is just going to be game over and it's
something this is something that
white starts to do now the queen on C4
is useless so Queen goes to E2
and the queen only two is simply
threatening to go to H2
unfortunately the moves there's show but
so King G7 played and now white so now
like this is my met with Rook h8 so
black is surviving
so there's no more checkmate
so what to do instead
this is a very common theme very common
tactic
I mean any kind of doubling on the H
file black will play Rook h8 so what we
want to do is we want to get the queen
first and then bring the Rook
I'm not allow we don't want to allow
gauge 8.
okay
so people in the class can see
it's not a big mystery yeah so here we
play Rook H7 and this is a very common
theme in this kind of positions so the
whole point is
to stop that Rook from going to age
eight so again if we play here
10 Rook h8 but if you play Rook H7
King so Rook H7 they just resigned
and if King here then Queen H2
and the difference is if King goes to G7
again we don't play Rook H1 on another
Rook h8 so we play Queen H6 first we
force the king back so now the Rook can
no longer go here and then we bring the
rook in
and now this is just Unstoppable mate
because we have two meets and this is
the problem with black being forced to
take H takes G6 because the entirety of
the H file is open so the queen can go
to both H7 and h8 and there is no more
Rook F7 to save this King
and in this position
instead of King G7 if Bishop G5 which
makes sense because maybe now the king
can try to run a native King survives
and it survives
then Queen H2 and King G7 so now if we
take
um
Knight takes or the queen takes actually
like something like this doesn't really
help because the king kind of survives
here I know it doesn't look very pretty
but
and if the Rook goes here I think Queen
F4
should be okay
oh actually Rook h8 here will be strong
because I see sometimes when players
attack like they don't so much think
about boxing their opponent's king and
it's just like just checking especially
like my beginner students when they're
trying to checkmate with like a queen or
something and then I see like the king
is getting checkmated on one side of the
board but they start checking and then
the king ends up on the other side of
the board and all of a sudden king is
not getting made it anymore so I
understand like this is tempting
sometimes it works sometimes it can
chase the king but if you box the king
in then that's pretty much it right like
we did in the game
so the king gets boxed in
and that's it the King has no Escape
Square so limiting the king's Escape is
a way to trap the king and Checkmate it
and it's kind of the same theme here
like if we play Queen H2 so Queen H3 is
threatening made in one
F6 of course doesn't help because still
made in one
so the King has to go to G7 and if we
allow this King to run to F6 E7 maybe
the king Will Survive there because
these Knights are not as useful in
attacking especially this b39 this B3
Knight is extremely useless even Knight
could go to D5 then be very nice but
this Knight is useless and this Knight
is also this G6 Pawn is limiting this
Knight
but instead um there's this nice tactic
here of Knight F5
and um
the idea is the same because she takes
F5 Bishop G5 so now if takes
again we play Queen H6 we push the king
back and then we check mate so we're not
like checking the king
and if okay this
there's no way this works because Rook
D6
and now we have this made into
well where we did this like if we think
about it we're not like again chasing
the king the Knight on F5 is also
stopping the king running from running
to the key squares of E7
so in Knight F5 they have to take and in
this position Queen G5 they have to give
up the queen
and white will be up a queen still some
work ahead to
to try to convert this advantage of
Queen versus rook and a knight but
because the king is still weak and any
kind of imbalance we have that involves
a queen we have to think about the king
safety so if it's like Queen versus to
Rook queen versus three pieces if the
king is weak then the king queen is very
strong and here the king is uh
um
and um
and here the king is just very bad
so after King just said like if they
played Bishop G5 then this would have
been the winning way but instead in the
game
King went to G7 and Rook H7 and the game
ended here okay we had two more games
but
well one of them was mine so not that
important
so we didn't get the chance to look
through of them but hopefully this were
useful at least entertaining examples of
the attacks in Sicilians some
interesting themes especially this one I
think with opening this how to open this
H files and with this Rook H7 ideas
well that was it for me unless there are
any questions
re-ending the Stream
oh yeah
because I don't think I can do it from
my end no no I I didn't know okay
all right
now all right good night
[Music]
foreign